this video is brought to you by
morningbrew
hi welcome to today's episode of cold
fusion
this will be the final episode of the
year
the world always assumes that google
services will be there
from gmail and youtube to online storage
search and smart homes we take it for
granted
each hour youtube has 30 000 hours of
video uploaded
google has almost 230 million searches
and an enormous amount of emails are
sent
in terms of connections google controls
about a third of the surface internet
but on monday the 14th of december 2020
all of google services suddenly
disappeared across the world
users were unable to access emails
kicked out of ongoing google meet
sessions
one twitter user even said that he was
left sitting in the dark with his
toddler as his google home system had
failed
the crash had become one of the biggest
social media trends it sent
waves of panic across businesses in many
parts of the world
how could one of the largest companies
suddenly go dark on all of its services
at once
what happened was this a hack in total
the outage only lasted one hour but had
already caused a lot of chaos
when it was all over most people forgot
about it and went about their day
but this event stuck with me when you
analyze the situation
some interesting things emerge not only
are consumers dependent on google
but many businesses that you may not
think are also is the world
too dependent on google and how does
google avoid downtime in the first place
in this episode let's take a look you
are watching cold fusion tv
[Music]
the google outage caused pandemonium
across the world
some of the biggest companies in the
country use
google and this includes uber airbnb
pinterest
netflix spotify twitter instacart the
list goes on
employees not able to uh
reach not just these services in terms
of gmail
but in some cases get into the system at
all
lots of companies use gmail to quote
unquote authenticate as you've tried to
get into
different websites and web services
salesforce dropbox so many others
that use google simply to get online
in certain cases that's inaccessible too
it's also hitting quote-unquote the real
world
nest heaters as you know that control
heat air conditioning and the like
those appear to be down as well across
the globe
there are companies literally in
standstill as we speak but we'll see
wake up call not like we're dependent on
this right i mean
this cannot exactly this cannot happen
this is this is it
this is it gmail google search
youtube google docs google drive nest
home systems
google play even stadia all gone
the wall street journal newsroom was
dependent on google services
so during the outage some reporters had
to resort to using telephones to
collaborate in writing stories
some schools in the u.s had to close for
the day wayne westland community schools
in michigan
gave its combined 10 000 students the
day off after google crashed
the school relied on google meet for
classes many other educational
institutions would have been affected
due to the prevalence of online classes
because of the ongoing pandemic
there were also cases of the management
of medical companies not being able to
check on the schedules of physicians
and other medical staff nor being able
to contact customers
remote work and learning have left
individuals and businesses
more dependent on online services than
ever and in this domain
google is the most widely used all in
all the outage affected billions of
people worldwide
so what happened a google spokeswoman
told the wall street journal that there
was a problem with the company system
that authenticates login credentials
she stated that the problem was due to
internal servers and that the issues
weren't the result of a cyber attack
this explanation doesn't give us much
but that's just about all that google
wants to say about the issue
as you'll see later in the episode just
maybe there was something more to this
outage than first meets the eye
[Music]
it really is rare for google to have
such a global outage like this
because even a single physical geography
is served by multiple servers across the
world and even on these servers
there's multiple backups that rapidly
come online if there's a problem
so as we've seen so much commerce and
people's livelihoods rely on google
it raises some serious questions what if
next time google was down not just for
an hour
but for days billions of dollars in
revenue could be lost by companies
around the world
so how does google prevent this how does
google basically never go down
google calls their plan to keep their
services up and running
site reliability engineering or sre
coined all the way back in 2006 sre
is a digital design philosophy basically
for google the idea
is to get software coders to run
software management instead of getting
it managers to run it
people call this kind of philosophy
devops basically
development software coding that
provides the outcomes of a system
administrator
the thinking goes as follows software
coders will get bored by performing
tasks by hand
and naturally build tools to help
automate the process without the
involvement of actual people
in fact google has written a book about
this which i'll link below
google states that sre is its most
fundamental feature
todd underwood of google in 2016 told
wide magazine
quote we long for the day when nobody
runs anything
it's interesting because traditionally
development and operations
were opposing forces the devs always
wanted to build new software and get the
changes out to the public as fast as
possible
but the operations staff wanted to
ensure that nothing went wrong
and the best way to do this is to keep
the changes to a minimum
the trick that google found is that if
you combine development and operations
you can get a powerful synergy for a
reliable system
it makes sense google is the world's
largest online empire
so the more humans you have running
things the more probability there is for
mistakes
so just have code run everything but
within that
human coders can still make mistakes
though another question must be asked is
the google empire too big
some say that google's outage
temporarily cripping the productivity of
billions around the world has just made
the biggest anti-trust argument anyone
could have ever done
currently google is facing off against
the us department of justice
for violating anti-trust laws so
according to the us government
the answer to the question of google
being too big is yes
it's the biggest antitrust case against
a tech company in
at least a generation here nothing is
off the table in here which could
include
a breakup of google the following
information is from today's sponsor
morning brew google's lawsuit is one of
the biggest anti-trust cases since
microsoft in 1998.
while monopolies aren't technically
illegal shutting out the competition is
the department of justice argues that
google illegally ensures
that its search engine is the default
option preloaded into cell phones
from apple's iphone to its own android
phone and this blocks out competitors
this lawsuit will take more than a year
to go to trial and it's one of many
anti-trust lawsuits against the company
you can read stories like this or
anything on business finance or
technology
at morning brew morning brew makes the
latest news fun and easy
you can get up to date with all the
latest breaking news in just five
minutes
all in one place without having to
trundle through different news sources
it's delivered to your email inbox each
weekday and saturday
click the link below to subscribe to
morning brew today it takes just 15
seconds to sign up and it's free
so where were we all of google's
services going down all across the world
for about an hour the result was
pandemonium across businesses and
individuals alike
and then we learned how google keeps
things running with site reliability
engineering
so moving on what about hacking
so to combat the threat of hacking
google often runs hacking championships
these feature hackers who report
security problems so that they can be
fixed before bad actors exploit them
google calls this the vulnerability
reward program and it was first launched
in 2010
according to google in 2019 the top
prize in this category was around 1
million dollars for hacking a google
pixel phone
though this next part is the interesting
thing the google outage occurred just a
mere few hours after it was discovered
that the us government had been targeted
by a foreign cyber attack
the hack was so serious that it led to
an emergency national security council
meeting at the white house
experts are calling it one of the most
sophisticated hacks ever seen
it was done through something called a
supply chain hack
a software tool called solarwinds that
was used by government departments
was infected with malware during an
update
after this the hackers were able to
monitor internal emails
and do some general snooping the
infected software update in question was
released all the way back in march of
2020
and lay undetected until last week
thousands of companies and american
government departments
use some form of solarwinds software
some affected by the hack
include the department of homeland
security department of justice
department of defense the treasury
department nasa the nsa
and more all of the top 10 u.s telecom
companies
and 425 of the us fortune 500 companies
are all said to be at risk it's
estimated that 18
000 clients had installed the infected
update ironically for the topic of this
video
solarwinds software monitors computer
networks of businesses
and governments for outages government
officials admit they were stunned by the
sophistication of the hack
and that many of america's most deeply
held secrets
may have been stolen they were able to
access different
levels of credentials in other words
they got in through the back door then
they were able to get into the front
door of
all of our homes and all of our
buildings and all of our government
agencies
as i was producing this video there was
some more breaking news
a microsoft security analyst believes
that there was a second group that
launched a second attack
on the same solarwind software it's an
evolving story and we have to wait and
see what happens here
so this is speculation on my part but
what if
this massive google outage was a
response to the solarwinds attack
google's staff may have been hurriedly
shoring up their security
and the scrambling resulted in some
downtime across all of their services
for a massive worldwide outage to occur
just a few hours after a massive cyber
attack on some of america's greatest
companies
is pretty interesting timing to put it
mildly
so linking back to the main topic of
this episode google's outage can be seen
as a stark reminder of our
hyper-connectedness
the company has become a bottleneck for
so much of the world's processes
it's become part of a massive system and
if it breaks
that also has massive consequences for
just one company to become an unexpected
choke point for global productivity
is pretty unnerving this whole
conversation
isn't even to mention privacy issues or
the shady origins of google
or having your digital profile sold for
ad revenue
so what can be done well the solution is
obvious
there's alternatives to google for every
service they provide
it really comes down to the individual
person or business what it all comes
down to
is trading in some of that convenience
that we've all gotten used to
so what do you guys think do you think
that the world is too dependent on
google
were you affected by the google outage
and if so what were you thinking at the
time
[Music]
i just wanted to say a big thanks to all
of you who responded to my post about me
going through some health issues
it's really nice to know that you guys
cared so i'm pretty much back at 100
now so it's all good that being said
this is going to be the final cold
fusion episode of the year
so i'm wishing that you enjoy your
holidays and i'll see you next year
if you want to follow me you can check
me out on twitter and instagram
and if you want to listen to some newer
music that i've made you can check out
my soundcloud
links for everything will be below
anyways my name is tagogo and you've
been watching cold fusion
cheers guys have a good
[Music]
it's me one
[Music]
[Music]
you